but when the heck did polarization
start to get worse uh because right now
people are kind of used to it but it was
not always this way that's right so in
fact you know i i kind of traced the
history of how we got to here and i
started in 1950 when the american
political science association puts out
this report
arguing for a responsible two-party
system and the critique of the u.s
system is that the parties are
indistinguishable from each other that
they're basically democrats and
republicans are basically the same
they're both in the you know these broad
overlapping coalitions of state and
local parties that don't really stand
for anything or they stand for the same
thing and voters have no meaningful
choice so what we need to become a a
real democracy is for voters to have
choice and for there to be two parties
that stand for two different things and
of course you know
nobody really listens to the political
scientists but that that prophecy did
kind of come true uh so starting the
1960s the you know particularly around
the
issue of civil rights the party started
to realign the democratic party since
the new deal had been a coalition of
northern liberals and southern
conservatives and you know once
democratic party comes to kind of own
the civil rights issue there go the
southern
conservative democrats who eventually
migrate into the republican party and
start in the 70s 80s
you see
culture war issues start to take center
stage more and more in american politics
and politics begin to nationalize more
and more and what happens is that the
southern conservatives go from being
democrats to republicans and a lot of
the northeastern
liberal republicans go to becoming
democrats so what used to be a kind of
four-party system a multi-party system
with liberal republicans and
conservative democrats alongside
conservative republicans and
liberal democrats basically collapses
flattens into a two-party system uh and
you know really this really
kind of
speeds up in the 90s there you know we
sort of think about the the gingrich
takeover of of congress as kind of a
watershed moment but what gingrich was
really doing in that election was he was
nationalizing elections uh kind of
taking away politics from the old every
all politics is local to focusing on the
national platform of the republican
party
and
really
engaging in a much more aggressive
attack on on the clinton administration
and democrats in general
and
that
really starts a a real
kind of kind of sea change in the
way in which elections are conducted and
the fact that the house had been in
democratic control for basically for 40
years up until that point there was kind
of a sense probably you know
from in the 80s and even to the early
90s that you know democrats basically
had the house and republicans were going
to win the presidency most of the time
and americans wanted divided government
so the party should work together well
clinton wins in 92 so now democrats can
win the white house
republicans take over congress in 94 so
now republicans can win the house and
every election is a toss-up election and
so the the the competitiveness goes up
of national elections and the parties
start to
to pull apart uh republican party
becomes more and more centered around
southern conservatives uh much more much
more conservative the sort of liberal
northeastern wing that sort of
represents the kind of traditionalist
you know kind of kind of
cautious
uh you know small c conservativism is is
gone and the democratic party which had
been split between kind of the the urban
you know northern liberals and the
southern western rural conservatives
becomes much more dominant dominated by
the northern urban urban liberals and so
the the images of the party
in the public mind become much sharper
parties stand for much
clearer differences and
swing voters disappear cross-pressured
voters are forced into one side or the
other and everything becomes about
winning the next election in which case
the party that is the opposition party
wants to make the governing party party
in the white house look bad so there's
no cooperation and all this kind of
ratchets
on itself keeps getting worse and worse
more demonization more sorting and so we
have this two-party system now in which
there's really no overlap in the radical
thing really is a genuine two-party
system in this country that that is the
the truly radical change
so we're
let's say 27 years in because newt
gingrich won in 94 right now so we're 27
years into this new polarization you
describe and your research
shows that we are unique in this regard
as well in terms of the depth of the
polarization right yeah
well i i mean not not entirely unique
this level of polarization
is uh what you find in hungary and
turkey so you know
we have some company
in not the company you necessarily want
not the company that may be although
apparently you know hungary is the new
there's the darling of the new tucker
carls of the tucker carlson right now
so again you know not necessarily
where you want to be in the u.s so i i
found your international research should
be fascinating where you you point out
that america right now is not normal in
terms of
uh various other democracies around the
world
uh there were some other findings i
thought were were fascinating too from
your work around the fact that because
there are two parties
the actual affection for one's
identified party is not as high as it is
in other environments
yeah so the cross national stuff is
really fascinating there's been a
growing amount of research on this in
political science so yeah generally
political scientists try
measure
kind of how people feel towards their
own party and how people feel towards
the out party so one of the things in um
it's not not surprising when you have
more parties people are more likely to
feel good about the party that they're
voting for because when you have five or
six parties you're more likely to find a
party that
speaks to you or speaks for you yeah
exactly
and whereas when there's only two
parties a lot of people feel like
they're voting for the lesser of two
evils or i don't really like either of
the parties but you know i gotta vote
for one because that's you know really
really all i have
so
that so that's part of it and people
people like their parties better when
there's more to choose from but people
also are okay with other parties and
multi-party systems a little more now
there's two reasons for this one is that
in the u.s system uh because people
don't really love their parties that
much what both parties try to do is to
convince people that the other party is
truly dangerous truly extreme truly evil
the only way to unify our party is to
have a common enemy so whatever
divisions we have you know we we can
work past them if the other side is you
know basically evil
also
because of the way that the
partisan polarization has worked in the
u.s most people are surrounded by people
of the same party so it's a lot easier
to demonize the other party when you you
don't really know anybody who votes for
them and people who vote for them are
people who have very different values
and live in very different places so
those two things contribute
and you know in a multi-party system
there's no lesser of two evils argument
because if there's five you can yell and
say the other party is too extreme but
then there's a bunch of other options so
that that kind of negative campaigning
is not quite nearly
as profitable
uh
and also be because there are multiple
parties there's going to be a few
parties of the left in more rural areas
and a few parties of the right and more
urban areas uh and so people are more
likely to know people who vote for
different adults it's harder to
dehumanize the other side if you
actually know people who are in that
party and you're like oh wait a minute
that person's my carpool they're not so
bad yes so i read something you wrote
that you suggested the optimal number of
parties would be between four and six
inclusive is that right
that yeah i would say between four and
six now you know i mean that's
that that's my assessment it's based on
you know a sense that
you know
more than more than six it probably
becomes a little harder to differentiate
between the parties for voters i mean
you know you want to give people some
choice but not an overwhelming choice
you know when you if you go to the
grocery store and there's you know 30
different kinds of
cheerios you know yeah streamline it for
me please yeah yeah give me some choice
but like you know i'd like to have more
than two choices of cereal
[Music]
you